good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 1170 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
due to the incorporeal nature of SCP
1172 it cannot be moved to a safe
distance from local residents as such
area 1170 has been built around SCP 1171
the entire apartment complex has been
blocked off however due to its rather
public location foundation personnel are
required to maintain disguises when in
view shift changes for guards stationed
at area 1170 occur every three hours no
personnel are to enter SCP 1171 except
in special cases under any circumstances
[Music]
description SCP 1171 is a windowless
bedroom located on the second floor of
apartment 21 in the apartment complex
British Columbia the room measures 8.5
by 11 by 3.2 meters with hardwood floors
and concrete walls
it appears empty on all security footage
the room cannot be illuminated by
visible light excluding the built-in
light fixture as SCP 1171 seems to
absorb all visible wavelengths the
interior of the room appears pitch-black
when viewed without specialized
equipment light outside the visible
spectrum appears to encounter no
resistance from a-c-p 1171 allowing use
of infrared and night-vision cameras all
light within wavelengths shorter than 1
meter is in some way affected by a CP
1171 it is not known whether radio waves
are also manipulated audio recording
devices have been shown to be at least
partially functional
as CP 1170 one's active anomalous
properties are triggered upon activation
of the rooms built-in light fixture
located approximately 0.75 meters from
the door on the west facing wall
subjects present when this light is on
claim that the bedside lamps in the room
activate
although security footage shows no
change in luminescence and infrared
cameras do not detect any heat source
other than the subject
in addition subjects describe the room
as having a bed a fireplace two bedside
tables and two lamps none of which
appear in the security footage it is
theorized that this effect may be purely
psychic in nature approximately one
minute in 30 seconds after the light
fixture is activated an entity hereafter
referred to as SCP 1172 appears on
night-vision camera though only barely
as wavelengths emitted are only up to 10
micrometers in length as CP 1172 s
anatomy is apparently humanoid except
for its inverted joints footage taken
shows no interaction between the subject
and the CP 1172 at some point between
two seconds and 40 minutes after a CP
1172 appears both it and any foreign
objects in the room including cameras
external lights and test subjects vanish
SCP 1172 is visible only to human
subjects who have been present in a CP
1171 for the entirety of the time
between the most recent activation of
the light fixture and the subsequent
appearance of SCP and 1172 exiting the
room is not recommended while SCP 1172
is present in the room as
it is unclear whether or not a CP 1172
physically exists or is simply a
near-infrared illusion produced by a CP
1171 subjects in sinus CP 1171 are seen
to converse with a partner while SCP
1172 is present the content of these
conversations suggests that they are in
fact speaking with SCP 1172 furthermore
the sudden emotional changes experienced
by subjects conversing with the entity
suggests that SCP 1172 may have a
mimetic effect as CP 1172 has avoided
all direct questions about any subjects
unrelated to love and romantic
partnership objects occasionally appear
at random in SCP 1171 most are mundane
and have no apparent anomalous
properties however there have been
several instances of blood appearing on
the walls roof and floor of the room
genetic testing revealed it to belong to
d-class personnel who had disappeared
along with SCP 1172 fecal matter semen
saliva and have also been recovered all
consistent with previous test subjects
and this is audio log 1170 r32 forward
the audio receivers during this test
were put on a frequency of as well as
being placed in new locations around SCP
1171 in hopes of receiving more
intelligible audio log begins
immediately after the manifestation of
SCP 1172 D 2019 2 is the sole test
subject playing log now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
afterward
less than four seconds after the
conclusion of this audio log SCP 1172
and D 2019 to simultaneously disappeared
from the room okay I think that about
does it for today thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and
you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's Sabah
Pablo ice 917 Kareem L going
Traver w peg white crew and jayvo Jack
Bryce and Bailey my archive curator neck
tie verbal courts five six three and the
wanderer thank you all so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the vulcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you